the AGT eliminations that shocked the
judges plus who the heck is this new
bachelor hey friends welcome to The
Daily Deni now yesterday I talked about
highlights from America's Got Talent
semifinals six acts got eliminated last
night so no matter what there was gonna
be some surprises but still two of the
most adored singers in the competition
axed even Simon was shocked the next act
going into the finals is
[Applause]
whoa
neither of you
I'm disappointed there being a need of
you gonna make it but listen you could
not have done any more that's the most
important thing you walk out with your
heads held high and up the night before
Johnny Manuel hit the stage performing
an original song but the judges
reactions were a mixed bag here's how
Johnny told me he thought about his
performance what did you make up the
judges criticism tonight cuz it was a
little checkerboard you know it's across
the board yeah you know what I've been
sick and I knew that I was struggling
with some vocal stuff and I knew that
there was a chance that the judges could
feel like I went the wrong way because I
wasn't able to fully deliver it I took
what everyone said too hard but Simon
was actually really nice if he moved to
me after and he said if he was in my
shoes he would have made the same
decision right listen that guy is on to
some big things but I've got to say that
perhaps the biggest surprise for me last
night brothers/sisters skating duo Billy
and Emily England did not make it
through to the finale
despite their flame-throwing
death-defying act I literally have not
seen anything like that on a GT before
and I thought that was an act worthy of
a Vegas show and million dollar prize
but apparently what do I know
clearly I have feelings about this but
we are switching gears now to another
shocking reveal the next Bachelor
yeah it's that guy meet season 22
bachelor ari
Lyon Dyke junior that's right it's not
Peter or Dean for rachel season it's
this guy and the news came as a shock to
bachelor nation with many on Twitter
calling out the 36 year old pic as old
and boring now up until last night
Rachel's ex Peter Krause was still the
front-runner but sources tell ET even
though he said yes he wanted more out of
the situation and after that ABC lost
interest because they were concerned
he'd be difficult to deal with but who
is Ari
alright born in the Netherlands fans
might remember the racecar driver as
Emily Maynard's runner up from season 8
of The Bachelorette The Bachelor fans
dubbed him but kissing bandit and he
even dated Bachelor bad girl Courtney
Robertson in her book she said he was
the best sex she's ever had
ari was originally set to be the
bachelor three years ago before being
replaced by Chris soules at the last
minute a source tells ET that incident
left ari embarrass and it's why he kept
the news
top secret till this morning the guy
didn't even tell his parents only time
will tell if he has what it takes but
expect a lot of kissing to happen but I
do want to know what do you guys think
of the bachelor pic shout out your
thoughts do you still wish was Peter you
can be honest
comment away now before we sign off the
latest reboot of Star Trek launches this
month on CBS all access and listen it is
not your grandparents Star Trek Star
Trek discovery features new characters
new missions and a new ship spearheading
that ship is Walking Dead starts an
equal Martin green who opened up to our
LeAnn Aguilera about the fresh take on
the old classic we've seen different
iterations of the Star Trek world but
there are so many firsts with Star Trek
discovery the first time we're seeing it
through the eyes of a female through a
first officer through of
african-american yes yes a female black
lead an Asian female captain of a female
captain with a female first officer
through the eyes of a first officer
first openly gay character in a TV show
of Star Trek it's it's a lot of firsts
we're doing our best to uphold the
legacy Spock is such an iconic character
and we do know that your character
Michael has a connection to the Fox
world what I do explain to the fans out
there who maybe are not as familiar with
the connection yes well I can tell you
that my parents died of a sternum my
parrot started a young age even when I
was when I was bringing and I it
happened at a Vulcan outpost and so I
was commissioned into the home of Erik
and Amanda who happened to be Spock's
parents
so essentially he's my brother now in
the original series Spock didn't
necessarily mentioned that he had a
surrogate sister so I understand though
that you guys are gonna pay homage to
bursting cannons you tease that will
that answer get revealed I will say that
Kanon is very important to us it's
everything it's our foundation and we
definitely honor it I will say that um
it will make sense it will make sense
we'll see just how much they honor the
original when Star Trek discovery
premieres September 24th on CBS all
access now before I go the time has come
for the daily Denny to take a day break
but don't worry we'll still have a new
episode for you tomorrow I just won't be
here to do it hit subscribe so you don't
miss my special guest co-host who will
be filling in for me but don't miss me
too much cuz I'll be back on Monday so
I'll see you guys then I'm off goodbye